الصين ينظم لنا الانصحفيه لمحل سياسي بس
الترجمان اهلا بك استاذ باسل هذه السياره
اللافته اليوم لرئيسه الحكومه التونسيه
الى الجزائر
بسبب انها تاتي طبعا للمره الثانيه خلال
العام همم كل الحاجه الاقتصاديه اليوم
ايضا لتونس الى هذه العلاقات مع الجزائر
وايضا هي تاتي من اللافت بعد يومين فقط من
رساله نقلها وزير الخارجيه الجزائري
للرئيس التونسي بنفس بالتالي كيف تقرا كل
هذه الحياتيات العلاقات بين الجزائر وتونس
المقبله في ذا القول ذلك
اهلا وسهلا في البدايه زياره رئيسه
الحكومه اليوم الى الجزائر تاتي بعض
اللقاء كان لقاء هام جدا جمع بين الرئيس
سعيد والرئيس الامريكي تبول خلال القمه
العربيه وكان هنالك تفاهمات اساسيه بخصوص
ضروره تنشيط العليا المشتركه بين البلدين
وهذا مجال الحديث عنه خلال اللقاء الذي
جمعهما القمه وايضا من اجل ان يكون هناك
اسرع في عديد القضايا الاقتصاديه المشتركه
واهمها مناطق تبادل تجاريه حر بين البلدين
على في عده مناطق حدوديه وايضا هنالك
التعاون الاقتصادي والتسريعه وبالتالي همم
الرئيس تبون من منطقه الحبس على تطوير على
ارسل السيد وزير الخارج الى تونس محملا
بالرساله للرئيس الرئيس همم ابلغ رئيسه
الحكومه بالتوجه الى الجزائر
في بدايه السنه القادمه اجتماع
العليا المشتركه بين البلدين والتي تعطلت
منذ سنوات الاسد جديد وايضا ذلك توجهات
اساسيه كبرى تخص التعاون الاقتصادي تخص
بين البلان بحكم ان يعني ديكتاتوريه
الجغرافيا التي تحكم علاقات الشعبين قبل
وجود البلدين وقبل وجود المنظوبات
السياسيه تجعل من الذي لا يمكن الهروب هو
تحقيق تكامل اقتصادي كامل بين الناس
وما وراء الاستفاده الاقتصاديه لتونس ما
الذي من الممكن ان ربما همم تتاثر بها عبر
هذه العلاقات
جغرافيا هي هي حكم الذي لا يمكن لاحد ان
يتجاهله او يتجاوزه او ان ينقلب عليه
وبالتالي هي علاقات تمددت على امتداد
التاريخ نحن اليوم امام حقائق قتل الحقائق
يجب الاستفاده منها ما يجمع بين الشعبين
الجزائري والتونسي من علاقات اخوه وروابط
وعلاقات تاريخيه مشتركه
لم يكن هنالك على امتداد تاريخيهما اي
خلاف لو شاهدنا كيف نجدنا الاتحاد
الاوروبي في تجميع دول حروب في قتل فيها
ملايين عندما نتحدث عن فرنسا والمانيا على
سبيل الفكر فذلك بعيد العلاقات الاخويه
التاريخيه بين الشعبين التونسي والجزائر
اليوم كما تعلم ايضا في المنطقه حلفاء
لديها عداوات هل بالتالي ما وراء الاقتصاد
في السياسه يجعل من تونس حليفا للجزائر
ممكن ان يؤثر بالتالي على علاقات الجزائر
بدور الجوار الاخرى
ليس هذا مطروحا بالمطلق لاننا في مستوى
تعاون التعاون الاقتصادي هي تطلبه حقائق
تاريخيه ولكن في مستوى كل دوله وسياستها
نحن نرى تباين في المواقف بين تونس
والجزائر فيما يخص الموقف في الانبياء
نعلم جيدا ان الجزائر تدعم السيده عبد
الحميد التي بينما تونس
على الحياد
هذا التعاون وهذا التنسيق الاقتصادي ليس
بالمطلق ان يكون تحالفا مع طرف ضد اخره
قال الاطلاق لانك في النهايه وحده الشعوب
المغاربيه والوحده المغاربيه المنشده هي
الامل الوحيد من اجل ان تنهض هذه المنطقه
وت من سباته كثيره
من تونس